oh my gosh
just after dawn on christmas morning the
quiet streets of nashville and its
residents
were shaken by the explosion which
police are calling
an intentional act
the blast next to an a t telecoms hub
destroyed nearby vehicles damaged
buildings
and disrupted communications across the
state of tennessee
the source of the explosion a motorhome
or rv
filmed arriving in the area five hours
previously
police were already at the scene before
the detonation
alerted first by reports of gunshots and
then by a computerized voice message
coming from the vehicle itself
telling anyone who could hear it to
clear the area
they received calls for shots fired i
had no idea what they were
responding to once they arrived
in the area uh they heard an rv giving
out a message
uh basically saying that it was going to
detonate within a certain time frame
and a countdown would go on and
and then it was play music and then the
countdown would start again
cctv footage has since been posted
online
showing the moment of the blast which
was felt nine blocks away
and heard for miles because of its
location
timing and the computerized warnings
only three people
were injured none of them critically but
police say they cannot confirm
whether anyone was inside the motor home
when it exploded
and there have since been reports that
human remains have been found at the
scene
the officers immediately began knocking
on doors
and evacuating residents here not
knowing if the
bomb was going to detonate immediately
or if it was going to go off in the time
that it was stated
these officers didn't care about
themselves they didn't think about that
they cared about the citizens of
nashville and they went in and we'd be
talking
not about the debris and that we have
here but also maybe
potential people no one has claimed
responsibility for the blast and no
motive has yet been established or
suspects identified
the authorities say they believe this is
an isolated incident
but downtown nashville has been searched
with sniffer dogs as a precaution
and investigations continue fraser
moored
sky news